okay we have a David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re
di t nearly 7,000 of our viewers and
listeners participating in respectful
political debate there a few interesting
discussions I spotted this morning that
I want to share with you the daily wire
is advertising on David's YouTube
channel so when I went to watch David's
video about the Trump lawyers letter to
Mohler I got a three-minute ad for
Andrew clavin's show on The Daily wire
needless to say I was a bit taken aback
I know David isn't a full time YouTube
creator like some others that's wrong we
are actually full time on YouTube it's
more of a side thing for him so I
figured there was a possibility he might
not know well actually we we have no
control over the ads that play and it's
interesting that Ben Shapiro's media
organization is spending money on our
channel but it's not anything we have
control over and they're probably buying
demographics they're not buying
specifically on our channel yeah if we
don't know how the ad system works on
YouTube I take it that the average
layperson and viewer doesn't know so I
mean I could totally understand this yes
and I'm glad for the opportunity to
clarify and have clarity this afternoon
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit grieving mother after meeting
Trump quote it was like talking to a
toddler yeah we didn't get to cover that
story on the show and I don't think it's
really a surprise to anybody that Donald
Trump has not had a tendency to display
what we would call normal empathy and
sort of reasonable human emotions when
he has been meeting with various
different people whose families have
suffered tragedies this includes gold
star parents and so many others so I was
not at all surprised that it was not a
great experience for another grieving
mother to meet with Donald Trump yeah I
take it that he's the same off camera as
he is on camera when you get him behind
closed doors he's still not gonna be
able to exemplify any empathy or care or
any of that stuff yeah I mean there's
all there's like the public persona and
the private persona of people and I'm
sure that there are ways in which Trump
is different behind closed doors I would
assume a lot more profanity but there
are some elements which seem to be sort
of his genuine personality also on the
David Pakman show subreddit does David
only have four finger
they seem like alien fingers and I
didn't see a fifth digit I don't know
where that comes from but it's a
surprisingly common question do I have
only four fingers on either hand but if
I do have five fingers on either hand
that I don't know if it's the angle or
how I cross my hands sometime but I've
got fortunately at this point in my life
I have retained all 20 of my digits yeah
do you think you've adequately debunked
that conspiracy theory well I think so I
mean all I can do is hold up my hands
and I very clearly have five fingers at
least at this point in time lastly
someone posted this video of alex jones
stalking bernie sanders at LAX at Los
Angeles International Airport I don't
know the circumstances under which both
Bernie and Alex Jones of Infowars
conspiracy Fame were at LAX it seems
like it was just a coincidence but I'm
gonna play a little bit of the video for
you and the video is particularly
interesting to me because the guy who
starts running interference and
explaining Bernie's like who is this guy
the guy who explains that it's Alex
Jones is Arie Rabin oft who's a contact
of mine I see him pretty often at the
Las Vegas conference organized by Mike
Papantonio he's a guy I've known for
several years was a Sirius XM radio host
I don't know if he still is or if he's
working more with Bernie at this point
but let's listen to a few seconds of the
video
Bernie getting accosted by Alex Jones
and good old Ari Rabin offed running
interference
well they didn't know Bernie Sanders
dude no come on now right now no why'd
you say why people who know us like
before the the best thing is first re
starts getting aggressive and like
stepping towards Alex Jones Bernie
immediately puts a hand on Artie's
shoulder and pulls him back and goes no
and then he says who is this guy and he
seems yeah if he was trolling like if
Bernie really knows who Alex Jones's it
came off so authentic that he just had
no clue who this guy was and then Ari
says this is Alex Jones and the video
goes on I'm not gonna play the entire
thing for you I encourage you to check
it out but entertaining video for sure I
kind of wish that Bernie was ready to
throw hands like jank at one of the
political conventions yes sir that would
have been that would have been a sight
to see
I would actually be interested in a
Bernie versus Alex Jones basketball
match we saw during the primary in 2016
that Bernie is pretty damn good at
basketball and Alex Jones is not
particularly what am I trying to say
here he doesn't appear to be in the
physical condition that would make him a
particularly good basketball player I
guess is what I'm saying and I would
actually be interested in one-on-one
with Bernie and Alex Jones yeah Bernie's
mid-range jumper is on point he's at
about 80% of the time yeah yeah in that
12 to 14 foot range Bernie is
unstoppable
among 70 plus year old white dudes